you there with the bear please let me  help you I will help you kill that bear  I'm very good at bear hunting oh you  guys already kill the bear I was gonna  help you  I got it thing alright well I mean just  let me know if you guys ever have bear  troubles again yeah don't sweat it  wait oh this guys having bear troubles  don't worry I'm Eric I know a good trick  it's to smash it with a rock alright I  know it's weak spot it's but it's the  butt of the bear we'll get it  this bear is dead gentlemen we may feast  upon the spoils go ahead it's all yours  I'm not gonna steal the bear from you  you have a bow and arrow and some sick  cloth armor go take it are you sure a  lot of food okay take the bear I don't  want it to spoil Oh  kourosh do you want this you can have  some bear I don't want to hog it yeah  dig in  that's good bear meat get in on that  bear oh cool thanks bro  you